is so fun i love that you're here i've
learned so much this whole show drew
and it's been really optimistic and
proactive i hate doom and gloom it
doesn't inspire anybody but we're
kicking off earth day with green news
and it's the perfect timing to do this
today
okay here is something to watch it's the
uplifting new documentary
the year earth changed narrated by the
one and only david attenborough
and you can watch it on apple tv plus
right now and it digs into the
incredible resilience we saw in nature
this past year
the unfortunate part of the pandemic we
all know what that was
um could it be a bright side to
really have come together in a way that
i don't think
anyone else anything else could have
brought us together
to see the ease
of our carbon footprint and what it did
for the environment and can we take this
with us into the future
i hope so i mean if if there's something
positive about covet like i feel weird
even just saying that
it's that we have seen sort of a
resiliency brought back
to um like endangered areas and
you know there's like rhino populations
that are now like doubling in size
because there's less tourism
we should acknowledge that well we
should and this has been such a tough
time for so many people and like
something good besides bridgerton came
out of this
right like it is amazing to see what
happens when we push
pause on on the carbon footprint
i'm optimistic for that as well danny
it's your story
next we've got a great new app now i'm
seeking italian to help you be the
conscious consumer you want to be
green queen reports the heel label app
lets you look up ingredients materials
and products to find out how they impact
four key areas your health environment
animals and laborers it works for foods
and fabrics so for example if you look
up acrylic
because they're everywhere as a material
you get this label
and you click through to get more info
on the environmental impact of this
material which is rated red
and see what the concerns are what do
you think about this app
well i think it's it'll be useful you
know like i have an
app for for my my diet where i can like
scan something and it tells me what's in
it and it's amazing because i think
about i want to put good things and do
good things for my body right so i can
scan
an item in the grocery store and it'll
tell me how many points what's in it
this is sort of doing that for the earth
yeah
right i think it's an interesting
concept but i
question you know who's actually
determining if it's bad
good or mixed is it a team of people is
it scientists is it one person
so i just want to get a little more
intel i like the idea but i think the
best tool you have is your intuition
but it is very confusing as a consumer
of what
what's good and what's bad i want to do
well but i don't know i don't know how
yeah well i know certain things are bad
for me and guess what
i do them anyway yeah girl ross your
story
all right next up drew i know you're
going to love this story it's the latest
in green
beauty marie claire just released their
list of 21 sustainable beauty
innovations for the year 2021
it includes shampoos deodorants makeup
and okay i know you love the beauty
blender drew but check out the
bio pure beauty blender it's the classic
blender tool but it's made with 60
plant-based materials and the company
says there this means less water waste
lower co2 emissions and 3 400 pounds
of virgin plastic saved and virgin
plastic is plastic with really
protective parents
i don't know what virgin plastic is
okay also to uh bio glitter is an ocean
fully bio-gradable body glitter as well
so the beauty industry
is uh taking note as well and doing
their part danny
what is the virgin plastic package
because i look at this
and i go great and then i go oh
dear but it's in all this plastic yeah i
mean it is recyclable
you know but i i kind of i agree with
you i wish it came in a
paper yeah i do too less is more less is
more the same way glitter less is more
how dare you
i feel attacked all right next we've got
the latest green tip on
tick tock eating well reports that you
can sprout an
avocado plant at home from a simple
avocado pit you know when you when you
chop into the avocado
you open it up it's got that little pit
inside danny walk us through can i
really do this
we can all do this you peel off the
outer layer that's going to be the most
time consuming this little brown skin
you see it on the outside and you get
this
oh really then you take a wet towel or a
paper towel if you want to reduce single
use
use like an old t-shirt and just get it
wet oh wow
cover the whole thing this is going to
create a nice little happy environment
put it in a reusable bag
not a single-use plastic bag let it
sprout you'll get in about two weeks a
little root
coming out and then you put it into a
happy little container like this where
the root is
making sure it's just touching the water
and in about 20 years
you'll be able to harvest an avocado all
right and before we go it's time for a
tasty bite of
food news all right i
danny do you mind just telling us the
story about this because i really want
to eat
okay this is my favorite recipe for my
magazine it is
vegan it's a chocolate cake it's nut
free so you can have it
but there's a secret ingredient in can
you guess what makes it so moist and
delicious
it's so delicious i'm trying to think
what would be vegan that would add
moisture
oil oh what is it vegenaise yeah
i love vegenaise so much you gave me the
vegan aids cookbook danny
which is great so veganised is your egg
binder here keeps it really moist it's
so
delicious so is it like a salad is that
what you're saying that like
essentially i can eat all this yes it's
stuff it's just like a salad um
it's my favorite birthday cake and you
know i don't know if you see this but
veganist recently or follow your heart
did a rebranding on their
iconic bottle it's so good but you know
i'm doing all these
prizes ross like throughout the show so
our friends that follow your heart
they want to celebrate their rebranding
and their new looks so
for your virtual audience they want to
help them read you their refrigerator
with a 100 gift card to go shop
[Applause]
i have to tell you when it comes to this
company this brand they are one of the
best in the business best in class as
far as you are like there is
no way this is vegan it will blow
your mind all of their products taste
like the real deal
and yet they're so much better for you
so thank you danny again
thank you oh my god thank you follow
your heart
[Music]